ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกวันดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สบายดีไหมคะน้องเรียมสบายดีค่ะพี่เอ๋พี่
เองสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะแข็งแรงแต่เมื่อ
วานเมื่อวานเหนื่อย
เมื่อวานทำอะไรมาคะเมื่อวานไปฟาร์มแล้วก็
เดินเดินๆ
ร้อน
ร้อนมากๆก็เลยเหนื่อย
ร้อนแล้วก็ไปปาร์ตี้อีกเหรอ
หลับนานๆเมื่อวานนะคะ
สบายดีนะคะมันแรงดีแข็งแรงดีค่ะถ้าแข็ง
แรงน้องเรียมวันนี้นี่มันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์
โรงเรียนได้ไหม
ได้ไหมคะอ้าวอยู่ตรงนี้
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
12 ค่ะวันที่ 10  12 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมก็เดือน 12 ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นเดือน 12
ปีที่เท่าไหร่คะปีพศ.
พ.ศ
2521 ค่ะ
2521 ปี 6 ต.ค.เท่าไหร่คะพ.ต.
ฉ
564 ค่ะ
2564 วันนี้วันที่ 12 อีก
อีก
29 วันไม่อีก 19 วันเหรอคะใช่มั้ย 19
วันใช่ๆอีก 19 วัน
2021 บ๊ายบายขอบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายเป็นไปเป็น
อะไรคะ 2,000
22  Oz  2022
ที่ 9 วันเย้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ 10 โมง
35 นาที
สิบโมง 35 นาทีนครูเรียมกับตัวเอกก็จะพูด
จะเสร็จตอน
10:00 น 11:00 นโมง 5 นาที
11:05 นนะคะใช่ค่ะโอเค
วันนี้เราเราเราเราผิดครูเรียมครูเอ๋เอ๋
2คนพูดว่าเราใช่เรามีอะไรมาคุยคุยๆให้นัก
เรียนฟังคะ
งูเมื่อคืนนี้ตอน
เมื่อคืนนี้เตรียมไม่ได้นอน
ทำไมไม่นอนเมื่อคืนครูเอ๋นอนมากๆเชื่อ
Skin ใช่มั้ย
ได้ค่ะ
อุ้ยเดี๋ยวนะคะมันวันก่อนเลยกดไวท์บอร์ด
แล้วก็ไม่กด
ไม่เกิดแทนสกรีนธอยู่ที่ไหน
ฮ่าๆๆเมื่อคืนนะคะ
เมื่อคืนไม่ได้นอนคู่เรียมไม่ได้นอนครู
เอ๋แน่นอนนะคะอุ้ยว่าพิษใหม่
อันนี้เตียงนอน
เตียงนอนคู่เอ๋น่ะ
นอน
ปกตินะคะปกตินอน 02:00 น
อันนี้
ปกติครูเอจะไปนอนตอน 02:00 นแต่เมื่อวาน
เมื่อวานวันที่ 11 ใช่ไหมคะ 11 ใช่ค่ะ 11
202  1 คู๋ The ไปที่นี่มีไปฟาร์ม
มิพระอาทิตย์รอ
หน้าร้อนคู๋เดินที่นี่
2 ชั่วโมง
เดินๆๆร้อนเหนื่อย
เมื่อวานครูเอ๋ก็เลยนอน
ตอน
21:30 นฮือ
อันนี้ไม่นอนเร็วๆนอนมากๆ
แบบคู่เรียมไม่ได้นอนทำไมคะ
เตรียมดูทำไม
คือมี
นะคะ
โคเรียมไม่นอนกูเรียนทำอะไรนะคะดูทีวีค่ะ
ทีวี
ดูดยูทีวีมีอะไรให้ดูคะอ่ะโป้เกย์ฟรีดับ
ปวดไม่ใช่ซีรีส์ไม่ใช่ซีรีส์ค่ะ
มีประกวด Miss  Universe
ประกวดผู้หญิงสวยไหมใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงสวย
her
เหมือนไหมผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะ
ขอโทษขอโทษขอรูเอกจะว่านรูปมงกุฎจะให้อ่ะ
กูเองว่าหนูกดแล้วกัน
เดี๋ยวมีสี่เหลี่ยมก่อนดีกว่าอ่ะซื้อ
หือเกลี่ยมาใส่สีดำไปเฮ้ยไม่ใช่
ออกจะเรียวนะคะ
มงกุฏก็โอเคต้อง 4 กลมใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
กูเอกจะว่าได้ไหมแอ๊ปเปิ้ลเลียม
ป่าววะๆ
ของมงกุฎคุยกับพี่อันนี้เป็นเพชรใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะและก็
มีแบบคลิปว่าปี Pop
her ก็กดใส่ที่หัว
ใช่ค่ะหัวผู้หญิงที่สวยจะว่าสวยมากๆใช้
ค่ะเราดูเราไหมคะใช่ไม่ใช่
กูเรียมดูทีวีค่ะทีวีมีเขามีประกวด
ประกวดถุ้ยผู้หญิง
เนอะ
ผู้หญิงสวย
ใช่คะถ้าผู้หญิงสวยก็จะไก่มงกุฏ
มงกฎอาให้ใส่มงกุฎฟรี
ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ดู Miss  Universe
เหรอคะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ดูทีวี
ก็
ตั้งแต่
มีนาคม
ผม
2021 ถึงธันวาคม
2002  1 ไม่ได้ดูทีวีเลยอ่ะอุ้ยทำไมคะหา
กูเอ
หรือว่ากูแอบอยู่ในโทรศัพท์เอ่อดู
คอมพิวเตอร์ขอดูคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็เขียน
อะไรไม่รู้เขียน
พิมพ์พิมพ์พิมพ์ไม่ได้ดูทีวี
เพราะว่าเวลาเปิดทีวีครูเอกให้เห็นโควิช
โควินโควิชโควิน
โดนไม่โอเค
พี่เอ๋ก็ไม่ดูไม่ดูทีวีตอนนี้เลิก
กันได้ดูทีวีไหมคะ
ดู
ประกวด Miss  Universe
นักเรียนชอบดูไหมผู้ถ้าสวย
ครูเรียมจริงๆอ่ะมึงต้องมันครูเอ๋ชอบดู
ชอบอยู่ประกวดมิสยูนิเวิร์ส Miss  World
Miss  Thailand  Miss  Thailand  World
Miss  songkran
มีลอยกระทง
ใช่ค่ะพี่
ทุเรียนมีไหมไม่มี
ไม่มีไหมมีแต่มีส
ผลไม้
ใช่มั้ยใช่ใช่แล้วไม้นักเรียนรู้จักผลไม้
แอปเปิ้ลสตอเบอรี่เชอรี่
ผลไม้ผลไม้อ่ะประเทศไทยก็มีทุเรียนมังคุด
เงาะ
ทุเรียน
จะคุยว่าให้
ทุเรียนอ่ะ We  Are
ทุเรียนหอมๆหอมๆค่ะ
มังคุดที่บางคนก็เหม็น
คนเหม็น
มังคุด
เงาะ
นี้ไม่ใช่พระอาทิตย์นะคะนักเรียนเงาะนะ
เป็น
เงาะเราจะเป็นปลมเนาะสีดำวัดครับผมกบ
กลมๆแล้วก็มีขนสีแดงๆ
นักเรียนน่าจะไม่รู้จักเนาะ
มั้ย
เนาะๆไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนไม่รู้จักไม่เป็น
ไรมาประเทศไทยใช่ค่ะมาประเทศไทยแล้วที่
เห็นก็เห็นเงาะ
ใช่ค่ะครูใจร้ายให้มามาแล้วก็จะได้เห็น
เงาะนะอ่าก็มีมีสอ่ะง้อราคาคะไม่ไม่ใช่มี
เนาะนะคะง้อ
ทุเรียนมังคุดเป็น
ผลไม้
ใช่ค่ะผลไม้ก็จะมีมิสผลไม้
her
เป็นผู้หญิงสวยๆถ้าใช่แล้วก็มีผลไม้
แล้วประเทศไทยมีอันนี้ด้วยครูเรียมนี่อัน
ไหนคะโอเคเอาอันนี้อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะเอาอันนี้
ออกนะคะเอามงกุฏออกนะคะได้ค่ะมีช้าง
โอ้ยยแต่
ถ้าค้าง
her
หางช้างจะมีขาช้างเนาะใช่ค่ะมีหูช้างมี
ง่วงช้างมีงางาช้าง
มิก้นหางมี / ช้าแล้วก็มีขี้ท้างคุ้ม
ที่พักขอเป็นสีเขียว
ช้างพูดมิสทำไมพูดช้าง้อมีประกวดมิส
ขา
ใกล้ค่ะเขาเรียกว่าธิดาช้าง
เป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงสวย
ผู้หญิงสวยๆ
นะแต่ว่าตัวก็จะ
จ่ายโตะอาอาหารอร่อย
หาเป็นชุดไทยแล้วก็จะใส่ชุดไทยเอออ่านะคะ
สุดท้าย
ธิดาช้างอ.หรอขอโทษนะคะครูเอ๋วาดไม่สวย
แต่จริงๆที่ด่าช้างสวยสวยมากๆสวยมาก
เดี๋ยวคุณเรียมกูเอกจะมีให้ดูดีกว่า
ถึงไหมอ่ะกูว้าว
เดี๋ยวเรา Stop แชร์ไปรับนี้พี่ดานะสวยๆ
สวยเนาะสวยมากค่ะง่วงอะเนี่ยมงกุฏแล้ว
มงกฎแล้วก็กินอาหารอร่อยนะ
สวยๆที่ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอคะเตรียมจะไปประกวดธิดาช้างได้ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้
ทำไมทำไมไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้เพราะว่าที่ดาชา
น้องเรียมหนักหนักกี่กิโลกรัมตอนนี้
เตรียมหนัก 51
เรียม 51 กิโลกรัม
ใช่ค่ะไม่ได้ค่ะต้องน่าจะ 80 กิโลขึ้นมา
วู
คิดว่านะต้อง 80
เตรียมต้องกินจะกินกิน
ข้าวเหนียวเตรียม
51 ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
เชิญ
ตัว a คะแล้วถ้าเรียมจะไปประกวด
Miss  Universe ได้ไหมคะเรียม 51 ใช่ไหม
คะกิโลกรัมไอเลียมเลียมสูง
สูงกี่เซนติเมตรคะ
158 เพราะ
วิ่งโอ่ง
158 เอ๋เห็น
วีดีโอครูเรียมกระโดดกระโดดมีเสื้อกระโดด
คิดครูเรียมสูง
170  cm โอ๊ยโอ๊ย
ไม่ใช่ค่ะอ๋อเรียมสูง
ใช่ได้
เตรียมไปประกวด Miss  Universe
ไม่ได้หรอคะไม่ได้เพราะว่าต้องบวชอีก
ประมาณแล้วกันนะคะ
12 ถ้าใช่เซนติเมตรท้ายเตรียมโคเรียม
เนี่ยต้องเพิ่มอีก 12  cm
เรียมต้องทำยังไงคะตัวเองว่าขวดมี
นิดอะไรได้ถ้าคุณสงกรานต์กลาญ
สงกรานต์นักเรียนสงกรานต์เนี่ยเดือน
เฮ้ย
เฮ้ยดีเดือนเมษายน
ประเทศไทย
ร้องร้อนร้อนๆ r9 ก็จะมีมีน้ำเนาะเป็น
ตลาดน้ำน้ำ
เป็นสงกรานต์
สงกรานต์เตรียมมิสงกรานต์โอเค
มิสคอมพิเศษที่เบิ้ลไทยโอเคอ๋ออ๋อขอบคุณ
ค่ะ
รู้เองต้องสวมมงกุฎแล้วนะคะกดให้ครูเรียม
ได้หาสวมมงกุฎ
ประกวดประกวดมี
ภาษาไทยพูดว่านางงามเอ้อใช่ค่ะนางงามใช่
มะประกวดก็คือจะนะคุยลบก็
จะมีผู้หญิง
ไม่ค่ะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงสวยและหาสวย
มากๆแล้วมันแข็งกัน
เราพูดมาประกวดมาประกวดกันใครสวย
ที่ 1
ขอดูอะไรบ้างครูเรียมที่สวย 1 หน้า
หน้าสวยหน้าสวยหุ่น
หน้าก่อนนอนน่าสนใจมากๆเมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนนะสวยเนี่ยต้องจมูกโด่งใช่มะ
โง่
จมูกโด่งๆ
อี
ดอกไหม
ผู้เรียนร้อยเดี๋ยวขอสต๊อกสกรีนก่อน
หันใหม่ค่ะกูเนี้ยหัน
คู่เลียมจมูกโด่งขอ
แบบนี้โอเคไหมคะโอเค
จมูกโด่ง
โอเคค่ะ OA ไม่โด่ง
จมูก Man จมูกแบน
วางวาง
ปากกาได้หมอเรียนกูอีกมากประกายได้เยอะ
เลยอ่ะอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ฮะโอเคอันนี้จมูกแบนฮะแต่มีมิสสวยๆคนไทย
คิดจมูกโด่งคนไทยคิดว่าจมูกโด่งสวยค่ะ
จมูกคนไทยคลิปนะคะจมูกโด่งนักเรียนคิดว่า
ยังไงคะจมูกโด่งสวยหรือว่าจมูกแบนเห็นไหม
ทำแบนน่ะจมูกแบนสวยแบน
แบน
จมูกโด่งหรือจมูกแบนที่นักเรียนคิดว่าสวย
ค่ะ
อันที่ 1 ชวบอกจมูกโด่งสวย
2 ก้า
ตาโต
ตาโตสวย
ความเร็วไม่
ก็ได้นะคะน่ารัก
น่ารัก
ตัดอุ้ยคูเรียร์มาตาโตอยู่แล้วตามโต
เรียงงานจนๆตาโต
โอเคนะคะตัว a  tato มั้ย
ปลาเล็กๆ
เคป้าเล็กๆน่ารักน่ารักๆๆ
เลยคะ 1 จมูกโด่งสองตาโต
ถ้าเบิ่งก่อนหน้าหน้าเขาบอกนาคลง
หม้อหน้ากลมๆนะกลมแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะกรม
รักลงกลมไหมแล้วเก็บไว้นั้น
ตกลงอ๋อ OK
คะเดี๋ยวคุยช้าจะกินดีกว่าจะง่ายกว่าอ่า
หัวหน้ากลมอะไรๆๆๆนาคลงชนะกรมเมื่อก่อนนะ
คะแต่ 2  2  3 ปีที่แล้วอุ้ยไม่ใช่ 5 ปี
ที่แล้วแล้ว 10 ปีที่แล้วหน้าตัววี
ออต้องหาตัว v ใช่มี
แบบนี้หรอคะเขาบอก Way  Tape  vps
beaches คิดว่าสวยใช่
แต่แต่ถ้ามีชีส Universe ต้องหน้า
ไข่
หมอนะลูกรูปไข่ค่ะนี้หน้ารูปไข่หน้ารูป
ไข่อ่ะอันนั้นจะเป็นนิ่ง
มีเสน่ห์
ๆโอเค
ว่าเป็น wee ผสมไข่อ๋อเป็นบีบี
ผสมกับไข่
โอเค
ไป Miss  Universe ได้ค่ะหน้า
8 สูงไม่ได้สูงไม่ได้ฮ่าๆๆ
[เพลง]
ขอดูล็อคคอเขาก็จะเอาคอยาว
โอเคโอเคคอยาวๆคอยาวแล้วก็หุ่นล่ะคะกู
ถ่ายรูปร่างรูปร่างเอาอันนี้ไหมครู
เหลี่ยมได้ค่ะได้ 5 คู๋ลบที่ด่าช้างนะคะ
ธิดาช้างคู่เรียนไม่ได้
ก็มีผู้หญิงผู้หญิงสวยๆนะอ่ะ
ที่ 1 อีกหนึ่ง
นักเรียนไม่เห็นคุย
1 จมูกโด่ง
สองตาโต
3 อะไรนะคะหน้ารูปไข่เนาะหน้า
รูปไข่รูปไข่อะไรน่างผู้หญิงสวยนะ 8
อ่าก็ต้องสวย
ปากสวย
ผิวราคาผิว
เมื่อก่อนต้องสีขาวใช่มั้ยสีเขา
หิวขาวอันนี้ทิว
ผิวสีขาวเมื่อก่อนก็จอดอ๋อ
ใช้กระดาษสีขาว
ก่อนมินางงามไทยต้องผิวสีขาวคู่เอกก็ไม่
ขาวนะคู๋หิว
คู๋ผิวสีนี้ให้เตรียมตัว a ผิว
เหลืองเหลือง
[เพลง]
เขาต้องเขาขาวชมพูชมพูอ่ะประมาณ
ขาวชมพู
ได้ประมาณนั้นอ่ะอ่ะไม่ใช่
[เพลง]
คนไทยเรียกว่า
ขาวอมชมพูใช่อ่ะนะอันนี้มา
เก็บกะกูอยู่
เป็นขาว
ขาวแบบนี้
ขาวชมพูชมพู
ใช่ค่ะอานิสวยมหาคนไทยคลิปแปล
ประมาณ 5 ปีมาแล้ว
สีแพนค่ะ
ใช่สีแบบกูเรียมหมอ
ความคิดเปลี่ยนเนื้อมือ
จะ Miss  Universe เปลี่ยนต้องไป
บาร์บีคิว
ผู้หญิงสวยผู้หญิงสวยตั้งวันที่นี่ก่อน
ค่ะ
แม่
อาอ่าอาบแดดใช่มี melawan อาบแดด R5 เรา
เรียกว่าชุดว่ายน้ำ
แล้วก็อาจจากสีชมพูก็อาบแดดจนผิวเปลี่ยน
นะคะก็เป็น
สีโอเคนะ
หิว
เปลี่ยนๆสีแทนสวย
[เพลง]
จริงๆครูเอ๋ชอบทุกคน
สีขาว
ก็
ส่วนสีชมพู
กระสวย
สีเหลือง
สวย
สี
แทน
สวยเหมือนกันใช่ค่ะใช่
สวยเหมือนกันตาโตก็สวยมากนาเระก็สวยนะ
จมูกโด่งสวยเอาจมูกเล็ก
สวยค่ะสวย
สวย 5 กะตะคนไทยน้องคนไทยคนไทยเมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนชอบผิวขาวอาหารอะไรค่ะตอนนี้
โอเคนะผิวสีแทน
ผิวสีชมพู
สีเหลืองสีขาว
โอเคโอเค
ค่ะที่เรียมดูเนี่ยอ่ะเมื่อคืนดู Miss
Universe จมูกโด่งไหม
โด่งค่ะตาโตมั้ยโตค่ะหน้ากลมเหมือนไข่ไหม
ลงค่ะ 8 พอดีพอดี
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้ต้อง
แล้วรูปร่างเออเดี๋ยวกูอ่ะลบตรงนี้ให้ลบ
ลบสีผิวปะรูปราบรูปร่างก็เป็นยังไงคะงู
ผอมของมากๆ
หอม
เกมเห็น Miss  Universe เดินเดินชุดว่าย
น้ำ
ชุดว่ายน้ำ
ช่วยไหมคะ
ผอมมากรูปร่างผอมมากเอาอ่ะว่าสวยผมยาวไหม
คะผมยาวค่ะผมยาวใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำ
ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นบีก็ถือว่าเป็นชุดเดียวค่ะเป็น
บิกินี่ค่ะ
กินไม่นี่ Love
อ้วนไปใช่ไหม
ต้องของวันนี้ใช่ไหมผอมมาก
ขอมอ๋อได้
เรียงคิด
เตรียมไปประกวดไม่ได้ทำไมอ่ะคะ
เตรียมไม่ผอม
อ้าวเตรียมไม่ผอมโอ๊ย 51 กิโลกรัมพร้อมนะ
พอดีพอดีเรียมสูงคูเรียม
สูง
58 น
The  cm
ใช่หนัก 51 กิโลกรัม
โอเคดี
พอดีพอดีสำหรับแข็งแรง
แค่เรียมพอ
41 กิโลกรัมไม่โอเคนะ
ใครให้ไปถึงเกออแต่ตอนนี้มีชีส Universe
รูปร่างเหมือนซุปเปอร์โมเดล
ใช่ค่ะมี Miss  Universe ของประเทศไทย
จะตัวใหญ่ถ.ชายหาดจะตัวใหญ่
ประเทศไทยตัวใหญ่แต่ว่าอะไร Miss
Universe ประเทศอื่นตัวทองใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
งูเตรียมก็
โอ้ว้าว
This  Is  Universe  Thailand บอกว่า
Real  size  Beauty
ว้าวเรียงชอบเออ
เพราะว่าไม่ต้องให้ผอมก็สวยได้ค่ะอ๋อ
เมื่อก่อน Miss  You  Miss  Thailand
Universe ไม่ผอมหมอ Miss  Universe ก็
ไม่ผอม
แบบเพราะเป็นมิสไทยแลนด์ยูนิเวิร์สเสร็จ
แล้วเปลี่ยนเป็น
ใส่เสื้อผ้าแล้วเดินที่แคทวอล์คเป็น
โชว์ซุปเปอร์โมเดลจะขอ
ป๊าตอนนี้ meet  you  New คนคิดเป็น Miss
Universe ก็เลยขอมรอ
the  world  He เดี๋ยวเรียงก็แต่รอรอดู
ทีวีเคลียร์ hey  hey  We  will  work
ไทยแลนด์ Miss  Universe  Thailand ยัง
ไม่เสร็จเหรอคะอย่างค่ะ
TV
แล้วก็อะ Miss  Universe  Thailand ให้
Champion  Miss  Universe ไม่ต้องของใช่
มั้ยไม่ต้องผอมก็สวย
ฉันนี่
เดี๋ยวคู่เอเชียด้วยดีค่ะดีต้องกดใช่ไหม
กดใช่ค่ะโทรศัพท์
เออนักเรียนเขียนนะคะ Miss  Universe
Thailand ใช่ไหมคะ Thailand  of นัก
เรียนเชียงอ่า Universe ของประเทศไหน
พิมพ์ลงมาข้างล่างได้นะคะถ้าครูเรียม
เชียร์ Miss  Universe  Thailand
ครูเอเชียด้วย Miss  Universe  Thailand
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวกูเอกจะไปดูกับคุณเรียมแล้วจะดู
แล้วก็เชียร์นะคะใช่ค่ะแต่เวลาวันนี้หมด
แล้วค่ะคุณเอ๋ออหมดแล้วอ่ะครูเรียมจะไป
นอนใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่
คลิปนี้หมดแล้วใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวจะมีคลิปที่ 2
นะคะ
ใช่ค่ะโอเคที่ 2 จะพูดเรื่องอะไรนักเรียน
ต้องรอดูนะคะถ้าแล้วนะเนี่ยอย่าลืม
คอมเม้นข้างล่างเทียมิสยูนิเวิร์สมั้ยอา
ชอบดูไหมนะคะครูจำชอบดูประกวด Miss อา
Universe ครูเอ๋เมื่อก่อนดูมากๆ
วันนี้ฟังครูเรียมคลิปจะดูค่ะเย้ไทยนั่น
ไทยแลนด์ไทยแลนด์โอเคไปเถอะไปแล้วค่าวัน
นี้สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋ดีค่า
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่
ว่าจะ